hmm you smell that
what is that
no
what's that smell what's that smell
what is that smell
is love
no it's the smell of cheeseburgers
that's right i've got another season of
burger scholar sessions my love letter
to the american hamburger
let's do this strange toppings for your
smash burgers check you ever thought i
could put marinade sauce on a burger yes
you can people oh god look at that
more international burgers got that
today we're going to take an imaginary
trip to australia
wait and you see what goes on this thing
it's
[Applause]
all right crazy going
freezing my nuts off in an outdoor
grilling episode oh yeah gonna happen
are you ready for some grilling secrets
the burger will speak to you oh my god
look at that thing thank you wisconsin
for this glorious burger steamed hamburg
history
steamed ham steamed hams who's hungry
let me explain what's going on in here
scientifically ah beef steam it's a
great name for a band
we all beef steamed special guests oh
you'll see
me
i'm here
that's right it's the canadian burger
episode let's do this you know the thing
that i love about you
is i've learned so much about burgers
everything that this man does
brings light and love into the world and
one lucky fan is gonna be here to give
me a hand i take hamburger history very
seriously and i know that after watching
this you will too burger scholar session
season five with me george mouse
[Music]
you